[Music]
hi I'm Emily Watson anti Elsa Einstein
ingenious third time I played this is
Geoffrey Rush and we actually have a
really nice working relationship we just
have that sense of feeling comfortable
together and we have a physical form any
era see what I've really enjoyed is the
factor Geoffrey and I look quite similar
we've both got these kind of really
great week and we're playing people who
go to the stage oh they just don't care
and that's really fun when we were
preparing active head I think we gonna
have to play this Tweedledum and
Tweedledee almost wins it away and their
productions
watching the content here comes the
Carson I have such a fine
imagine to me so clear and strong
why'd he find the rhythm storytelling
please
it was it's very exciting the idea of
his life sort of really on his own
without what I found for a modern
scientific route in making these immense
discoveries but also have been sort of
right center of history as the 20th
century on for quite exciting I hope
that's what people
[Music]